SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN A
BROADER GIL. ARCHULETTA. ASHBY.
ATKINS BECKER. BLAKESPEAR
BRADFORD CABALLERO CORTESI.
DAILY. DODD. SO EGGMAN GLASER
GONZALES GROW. OH, JONES THERE.
LEMON MCGUIRE MENJIVAR MEN.
NEWMAN WHEN NILO BY THE
PORTANTINO. RATH. VÚI SUHARTO
SKINNER, SMALLER CUEVAS STERN.
HAMBURG WAHA WIENER WILL.
MEMBERS OF QUORUM IS PRESENT.
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY. PLEASE RISE. WE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELE
GORMAN, AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. AS WE
GATHER IN THE PRESENCE OF THE
HOLY MAY WE RELATE TO THE SONG
OF THE BUILDERS IN THIS SHORT
POEM BY MARY OLIVER. ON A SUMMER
MORNING I SAT DOWN ON A HILLSIDE
TO THINK ABOUT GOD. A WORTHY
PASTIME. NEAR ME. I SAW A SINGLE
CRICKET IT WAS MOVING THE GRAINS
OF THE HILLSIDE THIS WAY AND
THAT WAY HOW GREAT WAS ITS
ENERGY? HOW HUMBLE IT'S EFFORT.
LET US HOPE IT WILL ALWAYS BE
LIKE THIS. EACH OF US GOING ON
IN OUR INEXPLICABLE WAYS,
BUILDING THE UNIVERSE. CREATOR
OF MYSTERY AND WONDER. GRANTS
THAT THIS DAY WE MAY GO ABOUT
OUR WORK. WITH THE HUMBLE EFFORT
OF THE CRICKET AND THE JOY OF
BEING HUMAN. WE ASK THIS IN YOUR
NAME. AMEN. MEMBERS AND GUESTS.
PLEASE JOIN US IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. I PLEDGE
.
MHM. THANK YOU TO THE STUDENTS
WHO JOINED US HERE TODAY. THAT
WAS FABULOUS. IT WAS GREAT TO
HEAR YOUR VOICES. WE'RE HONORED
TO HAVE YOU JOIN US? WELCOME TO
THE SENATE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON IN OUR AGENDA, PLEASE. UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. THERE
ARE NONE. MESSENGER MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE SET.
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. THE
FOLLOWING BILL PURSUANT TO RULE
29.10 SEE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B 610.
SENATOR WIENER. I UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE A NOTION NOTICE. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT ARRIVES AT THE
MIDDLE LETTER TO THE SENATE
DAILY JOURNAL ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND SENATOR STERN WERE
SUBMITTING THIS LETTER TO
CLARIFY THE INTENT OF SP 253 AND
SP 261 AS IT RELATES TO
WHOLESALE ELECTRICITY
TRANSACTIONS OPERATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR. THE LETTER HAS BEEN
CLEARED BY BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE. VERY GOOD, SENATOR DOLLY
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS, EVEN THOUGH REPUBLICANS
DO NOT OPPOSE THIS LETTER, UH,
WE OPPOSE THE BILLS. REPUBLICANS
HAVE NO JACKSON TWO LETTER AS IT
ADDS CLARIFICATION TO ENSURE
THAT THE LIGHTS STAY ON WHEN THE
WHEN WE NEED POWER, HOWEVER, I
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE ADDRESSED THESE
ISSUES LAST YEAR INSTEAD OF
HASTILY RUSHING BILLS THROUGH
DEBATE POLITICAL HEADLINES AND
GET THEM RIGHT THE FIRST TIME.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I WANTED
TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW
OUR SIDE OF THE AISLE IS
WATCHING CLOSELY AND THAT WE
NEED TO DO BETTER THESE BILLS
PROPERLY IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD. THIS IS,
UH, WITH UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON. AND IF I COULD
ASK YOU TO KEEP THE NOISE DOWN.
IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING YOU WANT
TO SAY, PLEASE GO OFF THE FLOOR
SO THAT WE CAN GET THROUGH OUR
AGENDA TODAY. THE NEXT ITEM IS
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILL'S SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 986. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE. SECOND
READING FILE. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 610. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. WE HAVE
THREE ITEMS. WE'LL START WITH
ITEM NUMBER TWO, SENATOR GROVE.
SHE HAS PREPARED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COULD YOU
PLEASE ASK THE FORMER SECRETARY
OF NATURAL RESOURCES TO STOP
DISTRACTING ME AND TAKE HIS
SEAT? IT'S SO ORDERED. THANK
YOU. COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO IS A CONFIRMATION OF HARRY
LEGRAND FOR THE APPOINTMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS. MR LEGRAND
IS A LONGTIME CAREER IN HIGHER
EDUCATION ADMINISTRATION WORKING
THREE DECADES IN STUDENT
SERVICES AND HOUSING FOR èC,
BERKELEY. UM SO THE BUDGET CHAIR
SHOULD BE 100% IN FAVOR. AND HE
IS CURRENTLY IN THE SPECIAL
CONSULTANT IN SAN FRANCISCO
STATE UNIVERSITY. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JANUARY 24TH IN A UNANIMOUS
VOTE RESPECTFULLY AS FEAR I VOTE
MEMBERS. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NONE. PLEASE CALL
THE WORLD AND IF I CAN REMIND
YOU TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL, ALLEN.
ALRIGHT, ARE BROUGHT TO JAIL.
ARCHER LETTER. ALRIGHT ASHBY. I,
ATKINS I BECKER ALRIGHT
BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
ALRIGHT, CABALLERO. ALRIGHT
CORTEZ E. ALRIGHT, DOLLY!
ALRIGHT, DODD. ALRIGHT, SO I
ADMIN. ALRIGHT GLASER. SALAS.
GROVE. ALL RIGHT, TODD Ó. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. AYE, LAIRD. I
LIMÓN ALRIGHT MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT,
MENJIVAR. ALRIGHT, MAN. ALL
RIGHT, NEWMAN. I WHEN. AYE NILO.
ALRIGHT. WHAT'S YOUR BY THE HI,
PORTANTINO. ALL RIGHT, ROB.
ALRIGHT RUBIO. ALRIGHT SO YOUR
TOE ALRIGHT SKINNER. ALRIGHT,
SMALL THREE OF US. ALRIGHT,
STERN. ALL RIGHT NUMBER ALRIGHT,
WELL HA HI WIENER. AYE, WILK.
HA! PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS RAFEAL. AYE. GONZALES.
TROUBLE. IS 38 NO. ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
SENATOR GROVE IS PREPARED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM
THREE COLLEAGUES IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF MARY SALAS TO
THE MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S MISS
SALAS WAS HAS SERVED AS MAYOR
AND CITY COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE
CITY OF CHULA VISTA. SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JANUARY 24TH ON THE UNANIMOUS
VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. MEMBER, SENATOR BLAKES
FOR THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO
PUT IN A GOOD WORD FOR MARY
SALAS. I SERVED WITH HER IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SHE'S
EXCELLENT, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NONE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALRIGHT ALBARADO GIL. ALRIGHT,
ARCHULETTA. ALRIGHT ASHBY. I
ATKINS ALRIGHT BECKER. ALRIGHT
BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT BRADFORD
CABALLERO. ALRIGHT CORTESI. I
DOLLY. ALRIGHT, DODD. ALRIGHT,
GOOD. ASO. ALRIGHT, EGGMAN.
GLASER. ALRIGHT GONZALES. GROVE.
HI, TODD Ó. ALL RIGHT, JONES.
AYE, LAIRD. ALL RIGHT, LEMON.
MCGUIRE I MENTIONED ARE ALRIGHT
MEN. HUMAN I WHEN NEIL Ó.
ALRIGHT, WELL, TRIBAL I BADIA.
ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT,
ROTH. RUBIO. SUHARTO. AYE,
SKINNER. ALRIGHT SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE, STERN. I AM BERG.
ALRIGHT, WELL HA! ALRIGHT
WIENER. ALRIGHT, WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
EGGMAN. AYE. GONZALES. LEMON. I
WHEN AYE, RUBIO. AYE. 39 NO.
ZERO THE APARTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES UM,
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF SHERIFF JIM
COOPER FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
COMMISSION OF PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING OR POST.
SHERIFF COOPER IS CURRENTLY
SERVES AS A SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SHERIFF. HE'S A FORMER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND ALSO PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS. MAYOR AND CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER OF ELK GROVE. HE
WAS APPROVED ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY 24TH ON THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. SENATOR ASHBY.
PASSED DOWN THERE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
WANTED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S JIM
COOPER, NOW SHERIFF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY PERSON WHO HAS
SERVED IN THE LEGISLATURE WITH
MANY OF YOU AND HAS DONE A GREAT
JOB IN AND AROUND THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO AND SERVICE
TO PEOPLE AND MY CONSTITUENTS.
URGENT. I VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NONE. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALRIGHT ALVARADO GIL.
ALRIGHT ARCHULETTA. AYE ASHBY. I
ATKINS ALRIGHT BECKER. ALRIGHT
BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
ZERO. ALRIGHT, CORTESI. DELI.
ALRIGHT, DODD. ALL RIGHT.
BAGMAN. GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE.
I HURTADO. ALL RIGHT, JONES.
AYE, LAIRD. ALL RIGHT, LEMON.
ALRIGHT MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT,
MENJIVAR. ALRIGHT MAN. I NEWMAN
I WHEN I KNEEL, Ó ALRIGHT, WELL
TROUBLE, PADILLA. ALRIGHT
PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT, ROTH. AYE,
RUBIO. SUHARTO SKINNER. ALRIGHT,
SMALLER CUEVAS. STERN. I AM
BERG. ALRIGHT, WAHAHA. AYE,
WIENER. ALRIGHT, WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ORTEZ
E. AYE. SO GONZALES. RUBIO? AYE.
SMALLER CUEVAS. WILK. I 36 NO.
ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO SENATE THIRD READING.
FIRST ITEM. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
UP HIS FILE ITEM NUMBER 10.
SENATOR ALLEN IS PREPARED.
PLEASE READ CENTER BUILT A 63 BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND ACT RELATING
TO ELECTIONS. SENATOR ALLEN
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE ABILITY TO
PROPOSE BONDS, CERTAIN
LEGISLATIVE MEASURES AND
AMENDMENTS TO THE CONSTITUTION
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CONSTITUTION FOR VOTER APPROVAL
AT A STATEWIDE ELECTION. STATE
LAW CURRENTLY ALLOWS THE
LEGISLATURE TO SPECIFY IN A BOND
OR OTHER LEGISLATIVE MEASURES
WHICH STATEWIDE ELECTION IT WILL
APPEAR BEFORE VOTERS. BUT DUE TO
UNIQUE PROCESS THAT I GOT TO
KNOW LAST YEAR, THE SAME
FLEXIBILITY DOES NOT EXIST FOR
PROPOSED CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS. AND SO THIS BILL
SEEKS TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
AND ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO
SPECIFY AN ELECTION FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT TO
APPEAR BEFORE VOTERS WITHOUT
ACCOMPANYING LEGISLATION, JUST
LIKE WE DO WITH BONDS AND, UH
AND ANOTHER LEGISLATIVE MEN
MEASURES WITHOUT I RESPECT FOR
ASTRONAUT VOTE SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
HAVE SOME, UH HELPFUL AMENDMENTS
AT THE DESK. VERY GOOD. UH ACT
SECRETARY PLEASE READ
AMENDMENTS. MY SENATOR GROVE SET
ONE. SENATOR GROUP. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TO AMEND SB
863 TO DELETE THE PUC S
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH AN INFANT
CAN BASED FIXED RATE CHARGE
PASSED BY A B 205 AND 2022 IN
APRIL 2023 REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
RAISED CONCERN WITH PROPOSALS TO
CREATE AN INCOME, GRADUATED
FIXED CHARGE AND REQUESTED THE
CALIFORNIA PUC REJECT A PROPOSAL
THAT UNFAIRLY TARGETS HARD
WORKING FAMILIES IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS. SEVERAL MONTHS LATER,
22 DEMOCRAT MEMBERS 22 MEMBERS
OF DEMOCRAT MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND ONE IN THE SENATE
ALSO RAISED SIMILAR CONCERNS.
SIDING WITH US ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE OF THE AISLE ABOUT THIS IN
IMPLEMENTING THIS POLICY.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE NATION'S
THIRD LARGEST ENERGY COST. WE
ARE CREATING ENERGY POVERTY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WHERE
BILLS ARE NOT SUSTAINABLE FOR
THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIAN
ELECTRICITY RATES HAVE BEEN
RISING THREE TIMES FASTER THAN
INFLATION. I BELIEVE IT'S UP TO
6.8% THERE IS NOT ONE PERSON
THAT I KNOW OF IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO GOT A 6.8% WAGE
INCREASE TO HELP COVER THESE
COSTS. ENERGY COSTS ARE SIMPLY
TOO HIGH IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN PUTTING FOOD ON THEIR
TABLE ARE PAYING THEIR UTILITY
BILLS. UM AGAIN, ENERGY. POVERTY
IS STRIKING US AND EVERY PERSON
IN OUR DISTRICT RESPECTFULLY FOR
THESE REASONS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. MAJORITY LEADER
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT. GOOD MORNING.
THERE IS LEGISLATION ON THIS
EXACT SUBJECT TODAY. THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE NOT GERMANE TO
THE BILL RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK
TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE AND WHAT WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE. MOTION IS TO
LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
IT IS NON NON DEBATABLE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. I BROUGHT A
GALE. ALRIGHT ARCHULETTA. AYE,
ASHBY. ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT
BECKER. ALRIGHT, BLAKESPEAR
ALRIGHT BRADFORD. ALRIGHT,
CABALLERO. ALRIGHT CORTEZ E. I
DOLLY. NÓ DODD. ALRIGHT DO THAT
SO ALRIGHT, EGGMAN. ALRIGHT
GLASER. GONZALES. GROVE. TODD
Ó. GROWTH. NO APARTADO. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. NO, CLAIRE.
ALRIGHT LIMÓN. ALRIGHT MCGUIRE.
ALRIGHT MENJIVAR. MEN ARE
NEWMAN. ALRIGHT WHEN NÓ NILO. NO
CHILD, BORG. NO. BY THE AYE,
PORTANTINO. HI, ROTH. AYE,
RUBIO. ALL RIGHT, SO YOU ARE TOE
NÓ SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. I STERN ALL RIGHT,
AMBER. I AH. AYE, WIENER. AYE
WILK. NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GONZALES. MENJIVAR.
AYE. I 31 KNOWS. EIGHT. THE
AMENDMENT. THE AMENDMENT TO LAY
ON THE TABLE IS GRANTED. UM
MOVING ON TO THE BILL IN CHIEF.
IS THERE ANY AH DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE BILL. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NONE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN, I. I BROUGHT A GILL.
ARCHULETTA. AYE, ASHBY. ATKINS.
AYE. FBI, BECKER. ALRIGHT
BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO. ALRIGHT, CORTESI.
HI, DOLLY. DODD. ALRIGHT, SO I
ADMIN. AYE, GLASER. GONZALES.
GROVE. HELLO. ALL RIGHT, JONES.
NO, LORD. ALRIGHT LIMÓN. ALRIGHT
MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT MEN, JABBAR.
ALL RIGHT, MAN. AYE, NEWMAN. I
WHEN NEELA. STRASBOURG. NÓ
ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT,
ROTH. RUBIO. ALRIGHT, SO YOUR
TOE NÓ SKINNER. AYE, SMALLER
CUEVAS. AYE, STERN. ALL RIGHT
NUMBER I WILL. HA! AYE, WIENER.
I WELCOME NÓ. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL. I
DOLLY. NÓ GONZALES. GROVE. WHEN
NO. NIELSEN. NILO. ALVARADO GIL.
I DON'T KNOW. I 30 NOS. SEVEN.
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM.
NUMBERS 16. SENATOR SKINNER. SHE
IS PREPARED. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 254 BY SENATOR SKINNER
INOCULATING TO CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. SENATOR SKINNER. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP 254 PLEASED
TO PRESENT IT. I RECENTLY TOOK
COST CUTTING AMENDMENTS, WHICH
REMOVED COUNTY AND LOCAL JAILS
FROM THE BILL. SO THE BILL NOW
ONLY APPLIES TO OUR STATE
PRISONS. AND AS A RESULT, OUR
SHERIFFS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION HAS
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. UM WHAT SB 254 DOES IS
PROVIDES JOURNALISTS LIMITED
ACCESS TO OUR CALIFORNIA PRISONS
. IT ALSO OPENS ACCESS TO
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE, THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND OTHER
STATE OFFICIALS. PRIOR TO THE 19
NINETIES, CALIFORNIA ALLOWED
MUCH MORE PRESS ACCESS TO OUR
PRISONS. WHAT SB 254 DOES IS A
LION, CALIFORNIA WITH MANY OTHER
STATES THAT PROVIDE UM, UH,
ACCESS LIKE THIS, INCLUDING
FLORIDA, MAINE, RHODE ISLAND AND
OTHERS. AND WHAT THIS ACCESS
ALLOWS US TO DO IS, FOR EXAMPLE,
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE, WE
CAN GET KEY INFO ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS THAT CONDITIONS SAY AT
OUR FACILITIES, THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED SO LET ME SAY
SPECIFICALLY WHAT IT ALLOWS OUR
NEWS MEDIA TO DO. IT ALLOWS THEM
TO TURA PRISON AND THE INTERVIEW
INCARCERATED PEOPLE DURING TOURS
IN PRE ARRANGED INTERVIEWS, SO
THEY HAVE TO BE ARRANGED IN
ADVANCE. THERE HAS TO BE CONSENT
BY THE INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL
AND OKAY BY THE FACILITY, AND IF
THE PRISON AUTHORITIES DETERMINE
THAT THE TOUR OR THE INTERVIEW
POSES AN IMMEDIATE OR DIRECT
THREAT TO THE SAFETY OR SECURITY
OF THE INSTITUTION. THEY CAN
DENY IT. SP 254 IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHER
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION, AND IS
SUPPORTED BY DOZENS OF NEWS
MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS. AND WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SENATOR CIERTO. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. UM ON THIS
ISSUE. I'M REALLY KIND OF TORN
BECAUSE WE HEAR THAT THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS TO THE PROCESS OF
ENTERING A PRISON AND HAVING
MEDIA ACCESS OUR PRISON
POPULATION AND BEING ABLE TO
INTERVIEW THEM. UM BUT PART OF
THOSE SAFEGUARDS. UH IT SEEMS
LIKE WHEN WE PUT THIS INTO
PRACTICE UM, THAT'S NOT WHAT
HAPPENS AND WHAT HAPPENS IS
MISINFORMATION LEAKS OUT. AND
WHEN WE GET, UH, INTERVIEWS WITH
PRISONERS, WHO SOME, SOME OF
WHICH HAVE SOME SEVERE
CREDIBILITY ISSUES. WHEN THEIR
WORD IS TAKEN OUT AND PUT OUT
INTO THE MEDIA FOR US TO
CONSUME, UH, WITHOUT A REVIEW OF
THE STAFF OR THE WARDEN. UM WE
WIND UP GETTING MISINFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN
PRISONS. UH I'VE I'VE BEEN ON
SEVERAL PRISON TOURS. I'VE HAD
NO PROBLEMS ACCESSING THOSE THAT
IS THE BEST TIME TO BE ABLE TO
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON. BECAUSE YOU
CAN SEE WITH YOUR EYES. YOU
REALIZE THAT YES, THERE IS
SOMEWHAT OF A DOG AND PONY SHOW
THAT MIGHT BE GOING ON. BUT
THAT'S WHAT OUR JOB IS, IS TO
DISCERN WHETHER THAT IS ACTUALLY
OCCURRING OR NOT. BUT YOU CAN
SEE THE CONDITION OF THE
PRISONS, THEN THAT'S WHAT WE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT. YOU
CAN. YOU CAN TELL BY THE RESULTS
OF WHAT'S GOING ON WHETHER
THEY'RE BEING UM, EFFECTIVE OR
NOT, WHETHER OUR PROGRAMS
THERE'S NO DOUBT WE ALL KNOW IT.
WE NEED TO IMPROVE THE WAY WE
RUN OUR INCARCERATION SYSTEM SO
THAT PEOPLE THAT CAN BE REHABBED
CAN BE REHABBED AND THAT PEOPLE
THAT AREN'T CAN'T AND WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM, AND
WE CAN CONTINUE TO KEEP THEM
SEPARATED FROM THE POPULATION
WHO THEY VICTIMIZED. SO I DON'T
SEE THIS AS A NECESSARY ITEM FOR
THE PRESS TO GAIN EVEN MORE
ACCESS THAN THEY PROBABLY
ALREADY DO. I THINK THE WARDENS
ARE ARE THE BEST PERSONS TO
ALLOW FOR US TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE CONDITIONS ARE GOING ON IN
THE PRISON. I DID GET TO TALK TO
INMATES WHEN I WENT THERE,
INCLUDING INMATES THAT WERE IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT AND INMATES
THERE WERE ON DEATH ROW. UM AND,
UH, THEY SPEAK FREELY, BELIEVE
ME. BUT WE CAN ALSO DISCERN
WHAT'S NOT TRUE AND WHAT IS TRUE
BY WHAT THEY'RE SAYING THE
INMATE I HAPPEN TO SPEAK TO
HAPPENED TO COMMITTED CRIME IN
AN AREA THAT I WORKED, AND I
ACTUALLY KNEW WHICH CRIME THAT
WAS. IT WAS REALLY INTERESTING
FOR THE WARDEN TO WATCH THAT
INTERACTION, BUT WE CAN SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE PRISONS.
WHAT WE DON'T NEED IS MORE
INFORMATION COMING OUT, UM, FROM
THE MEDIA, EAGER AND ESPECIALLY
NOWADAYS EAGER TO PAINT OUR
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES AS AS AN
OFFICERS IS BAD. OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE IS BAD. I
HAVE A PROBLEM RIGHT NOW WITH
MEDIA AND TRUSTING EVERYTHING
THEY SAY THEY'RE NOT AS UNBIASED
AS THEY USED TO BE. ALTHOUGH
THEY WILL TELL US THEY ARE AND
THAT'S MY CONCERN. I THINK WE
HAVE THE ACCESS WE NEED. I THINK
WE CAN. UH WE NEED TO WORK ON
OUR PRESENT SYSTEM. AND, UH AND
I'M GLAD. THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS FOR THE
CORRECTIONAL. I MEAN, THE, UH,
SHERIFFS AND A LOCAL COUNTY
FACILITIES BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY
CAN'T AFFORD TO TAKE RESOURCES
AWAY FROM THEIR ALREADY
STRETCHED. ISSUES FROM FROM THE
REALIGNMENT OF OUR PRISONS, UM,
TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THIS
TYPE OF ACTIVITY, AND THEN ONE
LAST THING ONE THING TO REMEMBER
, AND IT'S KIND OF LIKE IN FIRE
STATIONS. WE HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT THAT THAT'S ALSO WHERE THE
GUYS LIVED. AND SO WHILE THE
WHILE THE PUBLIC WAS ALWAYS
WELCOME TO COME VISIT THE FIRE
STATION. IT PROBABLY WAS
DISCOURAGED. THEY DROP IN AT 11
O'CLOCK AT NIGHT. THAT'S THEIR
HOUSE. THAT'S WHERE THEY DO GET
THEIR PRIVACY. AND WHEN THAT
PRIVACY WINDS UP BEING INVADED
BY OUTSIDERS WHO ARE TRYING TO
FIND A STORY OR TRYING TO CREATE
AN ISSUE, UM THAT'S NOT FAIR TO
THEM. THEY ALSO SOMETIMES
ESPECIALLY IN SOME OF THESE
ISSUES. THE INCIDENT WHEN I
TALKED TO THE YOUNG MAN, UM YEAH
, I WAS IN SOLITARY. UM HE
DIDN'T WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW WHERE
HE WAS. AND FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO COME IN AND VIDEO AND HAVE
THAT KIND OF INVASION OF THESE
FOLKS, PRIVACY'S I THINK THAT'S
WRONG, TOO. IF WE WANT TO MAKE
OUR PRISONS, UH, YOU KNOW, LESS
ONEROUS AND MORE RESPECTFUL AND
MORE HUMANISTIC, THEN THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
CONSIDER. FOR. NOW, THAT'S THEIR
HOUSE. AND WE HAVE THE ACCESS.
WE NEED TO DO OUR JOB. AND THE
MEDIA HAS IT WHEN THEY NEED IT,
SO I DON'T THINK THAT THIS BILL
IS NECESSARY. SO I WOULD URGE A
NO VOTE ON IT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. MENJIVAR THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I THINK THE
ONLY THING I AGREE WITH THE
SENATOR FROM YOUR ETA IS THAT WE
NEED TO CHANGE OUR PRISON
SYSTEMS. BECAUSE EVERYTHING ELSE
I THINK IS, UM, NEED TO BEACH
NEEDS TO CHANGE. I LIKE HIM HAVE
VISITED VARIOUS LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN THE PAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS FROM JUVENILE
HALLS, TWO WOMEN CORRECTIONS
FACILITIES RECENTLY, THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS WENT
TO THE CHOWCHILLA LOCATION FOR
THE WOMEN'S PRISON BECAUSE
CORRECTION OFFICER RAPED THE
MAJORITY OF THE WOMEN THERE. AND
IT WAS BEING HIDDEN BY THE
WARDEN THAT WAS IN PLACE THERE.
SO WE TALKED ABOUT, UH, A SYSTEM
THAT IS PARAMILITARY. YOU'RE
ALWAYS GOING TO LOOK AFTER YOUR
OWN. YOU NEED TO ENSURE WHEN YOU
LOOK WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING TO
OBTAIN UNBIASED INFORMATION THAT
YOU GET INFORMATION FROM ALL
SIDES OF THE TABLE. AND THAT IN
THAT CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD
WITH SO MANY OF THE RESIDENTS
THERE, THE WOMEN THERE IT WAS
ABOUT THE FEAR OF RETALIATION IF
THEY SAID SOMETHING CURRENTLY
WHEN YOU REPORT SEXUAL ASSAULT,
IT'S BEEN REVIEWED BY THE SAME
PEERS OF INDIVIDUAL THAT COMMITS
THAT ACT. THERE IS NO UNBIASED
INDIVIDUAL TO ADDRESS ANY KIND
OF CASE LIKE THAT. THIS BILL
FROM THE SENATOR OF BERKELEY IS
SO IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT WE
PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS OF THESE
PRISONS. I REPRESENT A DISTRICT
THAT HAS L, A COUNTY'S WORST
JUVENILE HALL. BARRY J. NORDOFF
WERE A KID OVERDOSED AND DIED
BECAUSE OF PROBATION OFFICER DID
NOT DO HIS ROUNDS DURING THE
NIGHT, A DEATH THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED. ANOTHER LOCATION
IN L. A COUNTY. WAS RUNNING A
FIGHT CLUB WITH OUR YOUTH. AND
JUST IN A PROBATION OFFICER'S
REPORT ON SUSPICION SINCE
PASSION WE NEED THE MEDIA TO
COME HIGHLIGHT AND ALL THE
ATROCITIES THAT ARE HAPPENING IN
OUR JUVENILE HALLS IN OUR
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES TO
PROTECT THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
UNDER OUR CARE. AND THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO DO THAT
IS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE OPENED
DOORS TO EVERYBODY BECAUSE I
VISITED ONE JUVENILE HALL AND I
WASN'T ALLOWED TO TOUR ONE
SECTION OF THAT HALL. EVEN
THOUGH I AM THE SENATOR OF THAT
AREA. SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE EXPOSING EVERYBODY
WHERE THIS IS NOT ABOUT BEING
BAD, ERIC. GOOD THIS IS NOT
ABOUT PUTTING OR PUTTING
TOGETHER. OUR OFFICERS WERE WHO
TAKE THIS HARD JOB TO DO TO WORK
IN OUR PRISONS IN JUVENILE HALL
IS TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE EXPOSING
THE GOOD APPLES WERE EXPOSING
THE WORK. THAT IS THAT IS
HAPPENING AND CHANGING, BUT
WE'RE WEEDING OUT THE BAD
INDIVIDUALS. I URGE YOU MY
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE AYE ON THIS
BILL. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SENATOR SKINNER, YOU
MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OUT. JUST
REMIND YOU WHILE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE ACCESS TO, FOR
EXAMPLE, OR JUVENILE HALLS AND
OUR COUNTY FACILITIES DUE TO THE
LOCAL MANDATE COSTS THAT IS NO
LONGER PART OF THE BILL, AND
THIS DOES PROVIDE US ACCESS ONLY
TO OUR STATE PRISON FACILITIES,
BUT IT IS STILL VERY IMPORTANT
TO DO SO. AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALRIGHT
ALVARADO GIL. ARCHULETTA ASHBY.
ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
ALRIGHT BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT,
BRADFORD. ZERO. ALRIGHT,
CORTESI. ALRIGHT DAILY. DODD.
ALRIGHT, SO ALRIGHT, BAGMAN.
GLASER. AYE, EGGMAN. I GONZALES.
GROVE. OH, JONES. LAYERED HI,
LEMON. HI MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT,
MENJIVAR. I MEN. AYE, NEWMAN. I
WHEN NÓ NILO. NO MORE TROUBLE.
BY THE PORTANTINO ALL RIGHT,
ROD. RUBIO. ALRIGHT, SO YOUR TOE
. NÓ SKINNER. ALRIGHT, SMALL
MARK WEBBER'S AYE, STERN.
ALRIGHT, HAMBURG. I HAB ALRIGHT
WIENER. AYE, WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL. DOLLY! NO.
GONZALES. BRO. NO. SO JONES.
NOW. GOLDBERG. BUT WATCH OUR
BOOK NOW. BY THE AYE. 29 NOS.
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
ARE GONNA TAKE A LITTLE BREAK
RIGHT NOW. DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA BE BACK IN
BACK. PAYING ATTENTION BACK IN
SESSION PAYING ATTENTION
TALKING. OUTSIDE. WE'RE STILL ON
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM
NUMBER 12 SENATOR BECKER LOOKS
PREPARED. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 719 BY SENATOR BECKER IN
RELATION TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES, SENATOR BECKER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
719. ABOUT RADIO COMMUNICATIONS.
WITH THIS BILL DOES WELL, LET ME
JUST START SO FOR 80 YEARS, NEWS
OUTLETS, JOURNALISTS AND THE
PUBLIC HAD ACCESS TO POLICE
COMMUNICATIONS FOR 80 YEARS.
ACCESS. AND. THIS IS, UH, ACCESS
HAS PROVEN TO BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY FOR
POLICE TRANSPARENCY AND FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY. WHOEVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS, LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE. MANY ARE STARTING
TO FULLY ENCRYPT THE RADIO
COMMUNICATIONS. AND THAT IS
CUTTING OFF VITAL ACCESS TO THE
PUBLIC. AND PRESS. LAST YEAR IN
MONTEREY PARK. DO YOU REMEMBER
THE TRAGIC SHOOTING WHERE THE
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT HAD
FULLY ENCRYPTED THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS. THE PUBLIC WAS
NOT NOTIFIED OF AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER. FOR FIVE HOURS. AFTER
THE MASS SHOOTING TOOK THE LIVES
OF 11 PEOPLE WHEN THE SHOOTER
WAS ON THE LOOSE. SO FOR FIVE
HOURS THE PUBLIC DID NOT KNOW.
AND BY PROVIDING NO ACCESS TO
THE PUBLIC. NO ACCESS TO THE
MEDIA. WE ARE SAYING THAT THAT
THAT IS OKAY. WE'RE 100% IN THE
HANDS OF POLICE TO DECIDE WHAT
THEY WANT TO RELEASE WHEN THEY
WERE IN, RELEASE IT WITH ZERO
OVERSIGHT. SO BASED WE'RE GOING
FROM A WORLD WHERE WE HAD 100%
TRANSPARENCY WITH MEDIA WITH
SCANNERS WITH EVERYBODY TO ZERO.
AND WITH THIS BILL IS SAYING, WE
DON'T HAVE TO GO. FROM 100% TO
0. POLICE ONE ENCRYPT THAT'S
GREAT AT THE G. O. J SAID THEY
DO HAVE TO PROTECT PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION PII II.
AND THEY SAID, THERE'S VARIOUS
WAYS TO DO THAT. THEY SAID YOU
CAN ENCRYPT UM, GRANTED, IT WAS
A BIT OF A CONFUSING MEMO. BUT
THEY SAID YOU CAN ENCRYPT OR YOU
CAN WRITE ACTS. YOU KNOW YOU CAN
DO THE FOLLOWING THINGS LIKE CHP
DOES RIGHT. CHP DOES NOT
ENCRYPT. UM YOU DON'T HEAR ABOUT
MASSIVE ISSUES. THEY'RE NOT
COMING HERE TO LOBBY ON THIS
BILL THAT WE NEED THIS. UH THEY
DON'T ENCRYPT. THEY'RE ABLE TO
BOTH PROVIDE BOTH TO PROTECT
PERSONALLY IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION. AND. TO UM UH TO,
UM, UH, YOU KNOW, TO BRAVELY
PROTECTED, UM, AND ALSO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO THE PUBLIC. AND SO WE
WORK ON THIS BILL FOR THREE
YEARS, SO WE'VE REALLY, UM I
THINK BENT OVER BACKWARD AND
HAPPY. I KNOW SOME MY COLLEAGUES
WILL SPEAK. SOME COLLEAGUES HAVE
CONCERNS WERE WILLING TO MAKE
ONE A MAJOR CHANGE THAT I'LL
MENTION IN A MOMENT. UM AND YOU
KNOW, WE'LL HAVE A NUMBER OF
MONTHS HERE TO WORK IN THE
ASSEMBLY. THIS WILL, OF COURSE,
COME BACK HERE, SO I KNOW PEOPLE
HAVE CONCERNS. UM, BUT WE'VE
REALLY WORKED TO DO THIS. WHAT?
SO NUMBER ONE ANYTHING. THERE'S
BROAD EXCEPTIONS FOR ANY KIND OF
INFORMATION, AND I'LL JUST KIND
OF READ THIS QUICKLY BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. UM SO THIS
DOESN'T APPLY TO RADIO CHANNEL
THAT'S USED FOR OPERATION
TACTICAL OPERATIONS THREAT OR
SECURITY OPERATIONS, UNDERCOVER
OPERATIONS OR ANY OTHER
COMMUNICATIONS THAT WOULD
JEOPARDIZE PUBLIC SAFETY OR THE
SAFETY OF THE OFFICERS HAVE MADE
PUBLIC SO BASICALLY IN THE
POLICE DISCRETION IF THEY'VE
ALREADY ENCRYPTED IF THEY FEEL
LIKE SOMETHING WOULD JEOPARDIZE
PUBLIC SAFETY OR THE SAFETY OF
OFFICERS TO MAKE PUBLIC THEY
DON'T HAVE TO DO IT. NUMBER ONE.
WE'VE ALREADY EXEMPTED THAT
NUMBER TWO. WE'VE GIVEN THEM
VARIOUS OPTIONS. WE DON'T WANT
TO PUT DIFFERENT COSTS. I KNOW.
UM SOME FOLKS SPEND A LOT OF
MONEY, ENCRYPTING. I THINK THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO DO THAT. BUT THEY
SPENT MONEY ENCRYPTING, SO WE
DON'T WANT TO PUT SUBSTANTIAL
COSTS, UH, ON THEM NOW, UM, AND
SO WE PROVIDE A NUMBER OF ACT
NUMBER OF WAYS TO PROVIDE ACCESS
THEY CAN DO WITH CHP DOES AND
SAY COME UP WITH, SAY. A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM OF HEY, WE
PROTECT INFORMATION ON THIS
CHANNEL, BUT WE USE THIS CHANNEL
FOR OTHER STUFF. NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO. THEY CAN STREAM ON
THE WEB. RIGHT UM VERY LOW COST,
IF ANY COST TO STREAM IT ON THE
WEB, UM, AS MANY CITIES STILL DO
TODAY, UM AND THREE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY CHARGE A REASONABLE FEE
IT SAYS RIGHT NOW TO JOURNALISTS
OR OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC,
BUT THEY CAN ACTUALLY CHARGE A
FEE FOR BASICALLY DECRYPT EAR'S.
THAT THEN FOLKS WOULD HAVE AND,
UM, SAY NEWS ORGANIZATIONS WOULD
HAVE SAY IN THEIR OFFICES. AND
SO I THINK THE CHANGE WHERE I
DID, YOU KNOW, HEAR CONCERNS,
ESPECIALLY MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO AND OTHERS. THERE WERE
SOME CONCERNS AROUND. UH YOU
KNOW, HECKLERS OR JUST MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC, UM, THAT MIGHT BE
LISTENING TO THE SCANNER. AGAIN
DOING THIS FOR THREE YEARS. I
HAVEN'T HEARD OF ANY REALLY
SPECIFIC PUBLIC HARMS. BUT THERE
I HAVE HEARD A LOT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT JUST RANDOM PEOPLE
LISTENING OR BAD GUYS LISTENING,
SO WE ARE. I'M WILLING TO MAKE
THIS CHANGE IN THE ASSEMBLY, UM,
TO LIMIT IT TO AUTHORIZED
REPRESENTATIVE MEDIA OR OTHER
INTERMEDIARIES. ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE SEAL IT OR SEE GIS.
CERTIFIED UM SAY, FOR EXAMPLE,
CITIZEN APP, WHICH LAPD IS
WORKING WITH, BY THE WAY, LAPD'S
WORKS WITH CITIZEN THEY'VE
ACTUALLY CAUGHT A CRIMINAL.
THERE'S A POSITIVE BENEFIT. THEY
ASKED THEM TO PUT IT OUT THERE
AND THEY ACTUALLY CAUGHT A
CRIMINAL VIA THOSE, UH, THAT
THAT SITUATION SO, BUT I AM
WILLING WILLING TO LIMIT IN THAT
WAY AND AGAIN. I KNOW COLLEAGUES
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT, AND UM
, YOU KNOW, WE'RE COMMITTED TO
DOING THAT. SO, UM LAST YEAR,
THERE WAS A BIG COST CONCERN.
MOST OF THAT WAS UC AND CSU. PUT
A MASSIVE PRICE TAG ON THIS OF
LIKE $7200 MILLION, WHICH WE
DIDN'T REALLY AGREE WITH, BUT
THAT WAS REALLY NEVER THE
TARGET, SO WE'VE EXEMPTED THEM
OUT OF UC AND CSU AND TALKING TO
MY COLLEAGUE, OTHER COLLEAGUES
FROM SANTA MONICA. WE'RE WILLING
TO EXEMPT OUT THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE. AS WELL. UM IF THAT
PARKS AND WILDLIFE IF THEY
BELIEVE THAT'S A, UM A FINANCIAL
CONCERN WERE WILLING TO TAKE
THOSE OUT AS WELL. SO UM AGAIN,
I THINK YOU CAN. YOU KNOW, SOME
PEOPLE HAVE SENT YOU THE L A
TIMES ARTICLE AT OP ED FROM 2022
, UM, BASICALLY, I DON'T THINK
WE SHOULD BE IN THIS POSITION.
BUT WE ARE IN THIS POSITION, AND
I READILY WITH THIS BILL SAYS
IS, LET'S NOT GO FROM 100% TO 0,
RIGHT. WE UNDERSTAND PEOPLE WANT
A CRYPT DO OTHER THINGS, BUT
LET'S PROVIDE SOME MINIMAL
AMOUNT OF ACCESS TO SOME BASIC
INFORMATION SO WE DON'T END UP
IN THAT SITUATION AGAIN OF A
MASS SHOOTER OR A OR OF AN
EMERGENCY. YOU KNOW A SOME KIND
OF NATURAL DISASTER OR SOMETHING
WHERE PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON. UM AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR. YES THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
FOCUS ON THIS TOPIC AND WORK ON
IT FOR THREE YEARS. I THINK IT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT THING TO BE
THINKING ABOUT AND I COME FROM
HAVING BEEN A JOURNALIST AND
WORKING IN NEWSROOMS FOR THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS AND THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES WHERE THE COPS
REPORTER WOULD BE LISTENING TO
THE POLICE SCANNER AND WOULD GO
OUT TO THINGS OR HAVE ADVANCED
HEADS UP ABOUT THINGS TO WRITE
ABOUT THE NEXT DAY. UM THAT LET
THE PUBLIC KNOW ABOUT REALLY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC SAFETY
INFORMATION IN AS IT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES, SO THEY
ISSUES AROUND ACCESS. UM AND
TRANSPARENCY, I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN I REACHED OUT TO
MY POLICE DEPARTMENT IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY ABOUT THIS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HE TOLD ME THAT
THEY EXPERIENCE IS PEOPLE WHO
ARE HARASSING AND TARGETING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FOLLOWING THEM
TO PLACES AND BASICALLY STOPPING
THEM FROM BEING ABLE TO DO THEIR
JOBS. AND I THINK WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AND OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES BEING ABLE TO DO
THEIR JOB. SO THE QUESTION OF
HOW DO WE STRIKE THAT RIGHT
BALANCE IS SOMETHING THAT I'VE
BEEN COMMUNICATING WITH THE
AUTHOR ABOUT UM AND THEN I ALSO
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT LISTENING
ON THE GROUND WHEN YOU TALK TO
PEOPLE WHO GO INTO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SOMETIMES THEY WERE
THE LITTLE KIDS THAT WERE
LISTENING TO THE POLICE SCANNER,
AND THEY LOVED THAT WORK. AND
THEY LOVED THAT THERE WAS A
PUBLIC SERVANT WHO WAS HELPING
INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE WITH THEIR
REAL LIFE PROBLEMS. SO I THINK
THERE IS A THERE ARE DIFFUSED
BENEFITS TO HAVING PUBLIC ACCESS
TO THE WORK THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS DOING IN REAL TIME. SO THE
AUTHOR IS HAS MADE A COMMITMENT
TODAY THAT ONE OF THE WAYS THAT,
UM, COMPLIANCE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT COULD COMPLY WITH
THIS BILL. IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD, WHICH WOULD THE BILL
WOULD MORE BROADLY ALLOW FOR OR
WOULD WOULD MORE BROADLY REQUIRE
THAT DEPARTMENTS NOT HAVE
EVERYTHING ENCRYPTED SORT OF
POLICE DEPARTMENT COULDN'T JUST
HAVE EVERY CHANNEL OF EVERYTHING
ENCRYPTED. AND SO ONE OF THE
WAYS THAT POLICE DEPARTMENTS
COULD COMPLY WITH THIS IS, UM
AND WHAT AND THIS IS WHAT HE
SAID PREVIOUSLY, BUT I JUST WANT
TO REPEAT IT IS TO PROVIDE
EQUIPMENT OR THE OPTION TO
MONITOR THE ENCRYPTED
COMMUNICATIONS TO JOURNALISTS OR
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA, AND
THEN IT'S FOR A REASONABLE FEE
TO BE ABLE TO COMPLY WITH OTHER
SECTIONS OF THE LAW. BUT I THINK
I SEE THAT AS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD UM, THAT WOULD REALLY
STRIKE THAT RIGHT BALANCE WHERE
MEET THE MEDIA WOULD BE ABLE TO
HAVE AN ACCESS TO THIS REAL TIME
DATA. BUT IT WOULD ALSO STOP. UM
ANY TYPES OF HARASSMENT OR
TARGETING THAT WE MIGHT SEE FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO MIGHT
WISH TO DO OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT,
UM HARMER OR ILL. SO I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY. I KNOW IT'S
GOING OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR
MORE ANALYSIS. BUT I THINK IT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT TOPIC FOR US
TO BE THINKING ABOUT AND I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR NOT
LETTING US SLIDE INTO A
SITUATION WHERE EVERY CHANNEL OF
EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE
STATE IS ENCRYPTED BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THAT THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IS BEST SERVED BY THAT.
THANK YOU. SENATOR SMALLWOOD
WITH US. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I ALSO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF SB 719 LIKE MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE. I SPENT THE EARLY
PART OF MY YEARS COMING OUT OF
JOURNALISM SCHOOL WORKING THE
NIGHT COPS SCANNER. UH AND I
WANT TO SAY IT IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT TOOLS WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT TRANSPARENCY. I
REMEMBER A CASE WHERE, UM WHAT
WE GOT OUT OF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN TERMS OF A REPORT
OF A SHOOTING THAT TOOK PLACE
THERE. JOURNALISTS HAD DIRECT
EVIDENCE BY BEING THERE EARLY AS
THE POLICE WERE ARRIVING TO GIVE
A VERY DIFFERENT ACCOUNT OF WHAT
TOOK PLACE. SO PART OF OUR
LAYERS OF GOVERNMENT IS A
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS, AND IN
THIS INSTANCE IT IS THE FREEDOM
OF THE PRESS THAT HELPED TO
ENSURE THAT JUSTICE WAS DONE AND
THAT FAMILY AND THAT PARTICULAR
CASE WAS SERVED. SO I STAND IN
SUPPORT. I'M GLAD THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS DONE THE WORK OF
WORKING THROUGH THESE ISSUES IN
TERMS OF GIVING OPTIONS AROUND.
UM UH, A REMEDY FOR DECRYPTION
THAT ALLOWS THE PRESS TO DO ITS
JOB, AND I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
MANY COMMUNITIES, PARTICULARLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR,
PARTICULARLY BLACK COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE HAVE STATE SANCTIONED
VIOLENCE AGAINST COMMUNITIES
WHERE NEIGHBORS AND RESIDENTS
ARE SHOT ON THEIR STREETS, AND
WE DON'T HAVE THE ADEQUATE
ACCOUNTING. WE NEED ALL HANDS ON
DECK TO BE A WATCHDOG. UM TO
PROVIDE THAT LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT CAN SAVE LIVES
AND MAKE SURE THAT COMMUNITIES
RECEIVE JUSTICE. AND WITH THAT,
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. SENATOR
CIERTO. THANK YOU, MADAM.
PRESIDENT I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL AND I RISE IN
OPPOSITION WITH A GOOD KNOWLEDGE
BASE ABOUT OUR COMMUNICATIONS
AND PUBLIC SAFETY AND WHAT IT
TAKES TO GET TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY VERSUS WHERE WE WERE 40
YEARS AGO. ONE OF THE BIG
DIFFERENCES 40 YEARS AGO, YOU
DIDN'T HAVE INSTANT
COMMUNICATIONS. THAT CAN
INSTANTLY SPREAD MISINFORMATION
OUT INTO THE PUBLIC BEFORE YOU
EVEN HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT'S
REALLY GOING ON. COMMUNICATION
SYSTEMS AND PUBLIC SAFETY ARE
EXTREMELY COMPLEX. WE CAN HAVE
AS MANY AS 20 OR 30, DIFFERENT
CHANNELS. THAT WE CAN, WE CAN GO
TO BE ABLE TO SET UP A COMPLEX
COMMUNICATION PLAN SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE VARIOUS TEAMS BEING
ABLE TO TALK TO EACH OTHER. AND
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT NUMBER
ONE TO UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITY
, IT'S NOT AS EASY AS FLIPPING A
SWITCH OR GRABBING THE RIGHT
RADIO THAT'S GOING TO
COMMUNICATE TO EVERYBODY. THE
NEWS MEDIA HAS ALWAYS HAD ACCESS
TO WHAT CALLS WERE HAVING THEY
THEY'VE HAD MONITORS AND THOSE
MONITORS MONITOR DISPATCH SYSTEM
. THEY DON'T MONITOR THAT
VARIOUS CHANNELS SPECIFICALLY
CHANNELS THAT WE HAVE, LIKE
TACTICAL CHANNELS AND IN SUCH,
BUT THEY MONITOR THE DISPATCH.
SO THEY KNOW WHERE THERE'S A
CALL. THEY KNOW WHAT TYPE OF
CALL IS GOING OUT. AND THEY KNOW
WHO'S GOING TO THE CALL. AND UH
AND MANY TIMES THE MEDIA WOULD
BEAT US TO THE CALL BECAUSE
THEY'D BE RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER COVERING ANOTHER ISSUE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. THEY BEAT
US TO THE CALL. AND NOT ONLY
THAT, BUT THEY BECOME PART OF
OUR PROBLEM. BECAUSE THE FIRST
THING YOU DO WHEN YOU GET ON
SCENE AND YOU'RE THE INCIDENT,
COMMANDER, AS YOU GOT TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE HELL IS GOING ON?
AND YOU CAN'T FIGURE IT OUT.
WITH A BUNCH OF PEOPLE RUNNING
AROUND. ADDING TO ANOTHER ISSUE,
WHICH IS WHO DO WE NEED? WHO'S
WHO? WHO DO WE HAVE IN THIS
SCENE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE EITHER PART
OF THE PART OF THE, UM THE
PEOPLE THAT CAUSED THE SCENE IN
IN CASE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT? UM
AND ALSO PEOPLE THAT ARE HURT.
AND PEOPLE THAT NEED NEED HELP
PEOPLE THAT BELONG THERE AND
PEOPLE THAT DON'T WE HAVE A LOT
OF SORTING OUT TO DO AND DURING
THAT SORTING OUT PROCESS
SOMETIMES THERE ARE CHANNELS
THAT WE HAVE. TO BE ABLE TO TALK
TO THE DIFFERENT TEAMS SO THAT
WE CAN UH AND WE CAN GET THOSE
DONE IN A WAY THAT KEEPS
EVERYONE SAFE, AND THAT'S THE
BIG DEAL. THAT'S THE BIGGEST
ISSUE WE HAVE WHEN WE GET ON
SCENE IS KEEPING THE PEOPLE THAT
AREN'T INVOLVED SAFE. MEDIA HAS
ALWAYS WHEN I HAD AN INCIDENT
COMMAND POST, I WOULD HAVE A
PLACE RIGHT BEHIND ME FOR THE
MEDIA. THEY COULD COME IN. THEY
COULD HEAR MY RADIO
COMMUNICATIONS. BUT THERE ARE
SOME COMMUNICATIONS THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO GO OUT INSTANTLY.
AND THOSE ARE THE COMMUNICATIONS
BECAUSE IF YOU IF YOU LOOK AT,
I'M GONNA GO BACK, 11 STEP HERE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT DEATHS ON A
FIRE SCENE OR A LAW ENFORCEMENT
SCENE OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
MOST OF THEM BOILED DOWN TO ONE
THING. AND THAT'S COMMUNICATIONS
. AND THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
COMPLICATED. WE HAVE ALL DAY
DRILLS ON COMMUNICATIONS. WE'D
GO IN EVERY MORNING WITH OUR
CREWS AND SAY, HEY, GET TO THIS
CHANNEL, AND THEY FUMBLE AROUND
WITH THE RADIOS AND DO ALL THAT.
AND THAT'S WHEN THERE'S NO
PRESSURE. WELL WHAT ABOUT WHEN
THERE IS PRESSURE ON ABOUT WHEN
YOU'RE UNDER DURESS? YOU KNOW, I
HAVE SOMETIMES WALKED INTO MY
HOUSE AFTER OPENING UP A COUPLE
OF DIFFERENT COMBINATIONS AND I
STAND AT MY ALARM PANEL, AND I'M
THINKING OH, BECAUSE IT'S
BEEPING WANTS ME TO ENTER THE
THING. AND I'M THINKING OH, MAN!
OH MAN UNDER DURESS. I CAN'T
EVEN THINK OF THE NUMBER TO UNDO
MY ALARM PANEL AND SO I HAVE TO
STEP BACK AND COME BACK AND
REGAIN THAT BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH
AN AUTOMATIC THING BEFORE. BUT
UNDER DURESS. THERE ARE STEPS
YOU CAN TAKE. YOU DON'T YOU WIND
UP. YOU'VE THOUGHT YOU'VE YOU
HAVE IT NAILED. AND YOU DON'T
AND THOSE ARE THE ONES WHERE WE
WIND UP, KILLING PEOPLE. AND THE
LAST THING WE NEED IS FOR THE
MEDIA TO HAVE ACCESS TO SOME OF
THOSE COMMUNICATIONS AND PUTTING
IT OUT. TO THE PUBLIC. THIS IS A
DANGEROUS BILL. THIS MAKES
COMMUNICATIONS EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT. THE MEDIA HAS THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO GET TO
THE INITIAL SCENE AND WAIT FOR
THE INFORMATION WOULD BE PUT
OUT. ANOTHER PART OF THIS IS WE
JUST HAD AN INCIDENT OUT IN THE
DESERT SAND BERNARDINO, SIX
PEOPLE SHOT, NOT A LOT OF
INFORMATION COMING OUT, AND THEY
WANT IT. AND THE REASON THE
MEDIA WANTS THIS. MAKE NO
MISTAKE. IT'S NOT FOR THE PUBLIC
TO KNOW IT'S FOR THE PUBLIC TO
KNOW AND TUNE IN. THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE RATINGS ARE GOING
UP. THIS ISN'T ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY. FIRST THIS AMOUNT
INFORMING THE PUBLIC SO THEY SAY
SAFE. IF THEY NEED TO STAY SAFE.
WE'LL LET THEM KNOW. HEY YOU
GUYS, THIS IS WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND THAT'S WHY IN THE ONE
EXAMPLE YOU GAVE. YEAH HOW DID
THEY? HOW DID WE USE THE MEDIA?
WE USE THE MEDIA TO CATCH THAT
GUY. THEY HAVE THE INFORMATION
THEY NEEDED TO GO CATCH THAT
GUY. THEY DON'T JUST COME TO
THING AND HAVE THE MEDIA SAY.
OH, YOU KNOW WHAT? UH WE'RE
GOING AFTER A GUY THAT HAS ALL
THESE CHARACTERISTICS AND JUST
DRIVING THIS CAR. AND THEN WE
FIND OUT THAT'S THE WRONG GUY.
THAT WASN'T THE GUY AND
EVERYBODY IS LOOKING FOR THAT
GUY BECAUSE THE MEDIA HAS PUT IT
OUT THERE. NO WE MAKE SURE THE
INFORMATION IS CORRECT. WE USE
THE MEDIA TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
PUTTING OUT CORRECT INFORMATION
TO THE PUBLIC SO THEY CAN HELP
US OUT. SO THIS IS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE DON'T
NEED TO MAKE OUR COMMUNICATIONS
MORE COMPLEX THAN THEY ALREADY
ARE. NOBODY'S TRYING TO HIDE
ANYTHING. IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
HIDE ANYTHING ANYMORE. IN THIS
DAY AND AGE. AND ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU HAVE PEOPLE OUT THERE WITH
TIKTOK. WITH ALL THESE OTHER
MEDIA THINGS THAT THEY CAN
IMMEDIATELY PUT OUT ON FACEBOOK.
THEY CAN PUT IT PUT IT OUT ON
TIKTOK. SO YEAH, AND THERE'S
JUST NO ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
INFORMATION THAT'S COMING OUT
UNLESS IT'S COMING OUT FROM US.
AFTER WE HAVE DONE A STUDY, UM I
WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT THAT THE
INCIDENT IN SAN BERNARDINO NOT A
LOT OF INFORMATION CAME OUT OF
THAT. YOU KNOW WHY? BECAUSE
THEY'RE TRYING TO CATCH THE BAD
GUYS. AND THEY DID. THEY'VE
ARRESTED PEOPLE THAT THEY THINK
ARE THE BAD GUYS. BUT IF THEY
PUT THAT OUT IF THE MEDIA PUTS
THAT, OUT OF THEIR INSTANT
ACCESS TO THEM TALKING ON THEIR
CHANNELS, AND THEY PUT THAT OUT,
YOU KNOW WHAT THOSE GUYS KNOW.
WHOOPS. YEAH, THEY'RE THEY'RE
ONTO US. THEY'RE GONE. WE'LL
NEVER FIND THEM. AND THEY'LL
THEY'LL CONTINUE TO BE DANGEROUS
INDIVIDUALS FOR THE PUBLIC. SO
FOLKS, I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THIS. AND STOP THIS NOW, BECAUSE
THIS IS SOMETHING WE DON'T NEED
THE INTEROPERABILITY ISSUES WITH
RADIOS AND TRYING TO MAKE THEM
SO THAT POLICE COULD TALK TO
FIREFIGHTERS. WE COULD TALK TO
THEM AND WE COULD TALK TO OTHER
CITIES HAS TAKEN HIS 15 YEARS
AND MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS JUST TO GET THERE. AND
WE STILL HAVEN'T ACCOMPLISHED IT
YET. SO LET'S NOT MAKE THIS MORE
COMPLICATED. THE MEDIA HAS WHAT
IT NEEDS. I URGE AND I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS ISSUE AND.
AND THIS BILL RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU, SENATOR PADILLA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
CERTAINLY HAVE GREAT REGARD FOR
THE DIRECTION THE AUTHOR IS
TRYING TO GO HERE. IT IS THE
CORRECT DIRECTION. I WILL
RESPECTFULLY BE STAYING OFF
TODAY, BUT I WANTED TO PUT SOME
COMMENTS ON THE RECORD HERE AND
I'M DEDICATED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO TRY TO
GET THE SUBJECTIVE ACHIEVED
BECAUSE IT IS IN EVERYONE'S
INTEREST TO HAVE MAXIMUM
TRANSPARENCY AND UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY IS DOING AT ANY GIVEN
TIME. IT HAS BEEN THAT WAY IN
THE STATE FOR MANY DECADES
BEFORE THE ADVENT OF CERTAIN
TECHNOLOGIES FORCED MANY
DEPARTMENTS TO BASICALLY TAKE
THE EASY WAY OUT AND ENCRYPT ALL
OF THEIR COMS. I TOOK A DEEP
LOOK AT THE BILL'S LANGUAGE, AND
I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR
THAT THEIR SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN
THE STATUTE THAT EXEMPTS CERTAIN
ENCRYPTED COMMUNICATIONS AROUND
TACTICAL OPERATIONS AND ALLOWS
THAT TO REMAIN ENCRYPTED IN REAL
TIME UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES
. I DO, HOWEVER, RESPECTFULLY
HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT THAT
LANGUAGE IS NOT AS CLEAR AS IT
COULD BE TO BE HELPFUL,
SECONDARILY WHILE I APPRECIATE
THE POSITION OF THE UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS WITH REGARD TO COST MY
PERSONAL POSITION IS THAT THAT
IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO JUSTIFY
EXEMPTION THERE. TO BEST OF MY
KNOWLEDGE. MANY OF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS IN THESE
INSTITUTIONS SERVE LARGE,
CERTAINLY DAYTIME STUDENT
POPULATIONS, AND THEY ARE 832
PEACE OFFICERS. AND AS A MATTER
OF FACT, IF SOME OF THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR OPENING UP
SOME OF THESE COMMS IN REAL TIME
OF POLICE DEPARTMENTS HAS SOME
PUBLIC SAFETY BENEFIT IN CERTAIN
REAL TIME CRISES, THEN IT WOULD
SEEM TO ME THAT ONE OF THE MOST
APPLICABLE PLACES TO HAVE THIS
OPENNESS AND NOT AN EXEMPTION
WOULD BE IN AN ACADEMIC SETTING.
IN A UNIVERSITY SETTING, SO I DO
NOT ACCEPT THE FACT THAT WE
SHOULD BE EXCLUDING THOSE 832
PERSONNEL AND DEPARTMENTS
BECAUSE OF COSTS ALONE, SO I
THINK THERE REMAINS SOME WORK TO
BE DONE HERE IN ORDER TO GET I
THINK TO THE LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT STRIKES AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE, AND SO, UH,
DUE RESPECT TO MY COLLEAGUE AND
MADAM PRESIDENT, I WILL BE
STAYING OFF THE BILL ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. SENATOR ALLEN. WOW
WELL, GREAT DISCUSSION, AND I
THINK THE DISCUSSION IS DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB OF POINTING OUT A
NUMBER OF THE COMPETING
INTERESTS HERE. EVERYTHING FROM
PRESS ACCESS AND TRANSPARENCY TO
SOME VERY SERIOUS ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH IMPLEMENTATION
AND POTENTIALLY IMPACTING THE
EFFICACY OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
DOING ITS WORK. AH, YOU KNOW,
I'M I'M THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST A
LOT OF ISSUES. I THINK IT STILL
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN THIS
BILL. IF THIS IS GOING TO BE
READY FOR PRIME TIME YOU KNOW,
AND I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A LOT
OF TRICKY ISSUES THAT THE AUTHOR
HAS BEEN WORKING ON
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES THAT STILL
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. I DO THINK
YOU KNOW, WITH WITH RESPECT TO
MY VERY MUCH RESPECTED MY
COLLEAGUES, PREVIOUS COMMENTS I
DO THINK WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THE COST. YOU KNOW THE REASON
WHY THE CSU AND UC WERE DROPPED
FROM THE BILLS BECAUSE DO YOU
HAVE? IT ESTIMATED THAT THIS
BILL WOULD IMPLEMENT WOULD
IMPOSE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF COSTS ON THOSE TWO
ENTITIES. I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR, MAKING HIS COMMITMENT TO
DROP PARKS AND RECREATION
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE,
ESPECIALLY IN A YEAR LIKE THIS
FROM THE BILL. UM YOU KNOW, I
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
YOU KNOW PART OF THE BUF
ANALYSIS DID NOT GIVE A SPECIFIC
AH ESTIMATE AS TO THE COST OF
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT, BUT BUT
IT DID SAY, TENDS TO HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS. SO, YOU KNOW. I DON'T
THINK ANY REASONABLE FEE FOR
DESCRIPTORS IS GOING TO MAKE UP
THAT COST THAT WERE THAT WE
WOULD POTENTIALLY BE IMPOSING
UPON OUR ENTIRE PUBLIC SECTOR
THROUGH THIS. SO THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT THE AUTHOR REALLY
NEEDS TO WORK ON, REALLY FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO MAKE THIS A
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE COST
EFFECTIVE. EFFORT. I THINK WE
NEED A TIGHTER DEFINITION WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT ABOUT PEOPLE
WANTING MEDIA TO HAVE ACCESS. I
UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW, MY OTHER
COLLEAGUE, UH, MENTIONS THAT
THERE MAY BE, YOU KNOW. MAYBE
MAYBE MAYBE THE YOU KNOW THAT
MAYBE MEDIA DOESN'T NEED TO HAVE
AS MUCH ACCESS. UM, I THINK
THERE'S A STRONG PUBLIC INTEREST
IN MEDIA ACCESS. BUT I ALSO
THINK THAT THE DEFINITION THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW IN SB
98 IS NOT TIGHT ENOUGH. YOU HAVE
A LOT OF FLY BY NIGHT FOLKS OUT
THERE THAT CLAIM MEDIA
CREDENTIAL, AND YET THEY'RE
REALLY OUT THERE TRYING TO
INCITE. I WAS SHOWING A PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY FACEBOOK PAGE,
RIGHT BASED RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT IS JUST FULL OF
BLOOD AND GUTS AND GORE. YOU
KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN USED
WHERE FOLKS HAVE BEEN USING THE
ACCESS TO THE DISPATCH. ANOTHER
ISSUE IS, UM THIS WHOLE QUESTION
OF TACTICAL CHANNEL VERSUS
DISPATCH CHANNEL. NOW I'M SURE
THE AUTHOR WILL POINT OUT
LANGUAGE THAT HE HAS IN THE BILL
SECTION. UH A THREE B, WHICH
WHICH DOES EXEMPT RADIO CHANNELS
THAT ARE USED FOR TACTICAL
OPERATIONS, THREAT OR SECURITY
OPERATIONS, UNDERCOVER
OPERATIONS OR OTHER
COMMUNICATIONS THAT WOULD
JEOPARDIZE PUBLIC SAFETY OR THE
SAFETY OF OFFICERS HAVE MADE
PUBLIC. I ALSO KNOW THAT THE
FOLKS FROM THE POLICE CHIEFS
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT AMBIGUITY
BECAUSE OF PREVIOUS LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL TALKING ABOUT, UH,
PROVIDING ACCESS TO ENCRYPTED
COMMUNICATIONS TO ANY INTERESTED
PERSON, SO THAT'S ANOTHER
AMBIGUITY. I THINK THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED, SO UM, YOU KNOW,
I'M I'M WATCHING THE FLOOR
DEBATE. I'M YOU KNOW, I KNOW THE
AUTHOR AND I LIKE HIM, AND I
KNOW THAT HE'S A CAPABLE PERSON.
AND I CERTAINLY YOU KNOW, THERE
ARE LOTS OF VERY UH YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE WORKS OF PROGRESS THAT
YOU GO THROUGH THIS LEGISLATURE
AT MY MYSELF ENGAGED IN THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT IT YESTERDAY WITH,
YOU KNOW, ON ANOTHER BILL, SO I
KNOW THIS IS GOING TO FACE IT
REALLY HARD HEARING. IN THE
ASSEMBLY BECAUSE OF ALL THESE
ISSUES. THESE ARE A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE RESOLVED.
UH SO I'M I'M CERTAINLY WOULD
NOT FEEL ANYWHERE CLOSE TO
COMFORTABLE VOTING FOR THIS IF
THIS WERE GOING OUT OF THE GOING
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK, I'M
WATCHING THE FLOOR DEBATE BUT
WILLING TO CONSIDER SUPPORTING
IT TODAY, UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED WITH THIS
BILL. SENATOR EMBURGH. UM
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR. SENATOR
BECKER WILL QUESTION HE WILL
TAKE IT. UM APPROPRIATE TO THE
QUESTION IS TO FOLLOW ON MY
COLLEAGUE'S COMMENT FROM SANTA
MONICA. THERE IS A CLASH OF
VALUES HERE. THERE'S A CLASH OF
VALUES. THE TRANSPARENCY VALUE
WE HAVE AN INTEREST IS
POLICYMAKERS AND MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE THAT PROTECT US ARE
DOING SO IN A WAY THAT ADHERES
TO THE LAW AND MONITORING
COMMUNICATIONS IS THAT WAS A WAY
TO DO THAT, AND I AGREE WITH THE
AUTHOR'S CONCERNED. UM I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY,
THOUGH ABOUT THE DISSEMINATION
REAL TIME IN THE THEORY THAT
SOMEHOW THAT THE GENERAL PUBLIC
CAN DO, UM, EITHER A BETTER JOB
OR A COMPLIMENTARY JOB TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEN THERE IS AN
ISSUE THAT FOLKS WITH GUNS
SHOWING UP IF THERE'S A, FOR
EXAMPLE, A MASS SHOOTING THAT
KIND OF THING I'M GRAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT. BUT I ASKED THE
AUTHOR IF THE AUTHOR WOULD
CONSIDER SIMPLY ADDRESSING THAT
TRANSPARENCY CONCERN BY
REQUIRING THAT THESE
COMMUNICATIONS BE PRESERVED AND
THEN PROVIDED AT A LATER TIME
NOT FAR DISTANT 24 HOURS LATER,
12 HOURS, BUT AFTER THE EMERGENT
EVENT HAS BASICALLY DISSIPATED.
SO LET ME ASK THE AUTHOR OF THAT
QUESTION. IF I MIGHT I
APPRECIATE THAT, AND I'LL
ADDRESS THE REST OF STUFF MY
CLOTHES, BUT SPECIFICALLY TO
YOUR QUESTION, UM, WILLING TO
LOOK AT THAT. UM I HADN'T HEARD
THAT DIRECTLY FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS A BIG ISSUE. I DO
KNOW THERE ARE THEIR CITIES. I
THINK SAN DIEGO DOES FIVE
MINUTES. I NEED, YOU KNOW, UM,
DELAY. SO UM, I'M WILLING TO
LOOK AT THAT. I WANT TO, YOU
KNOW, TALK TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND SEE HOW THEY FEEL. IF THAT
YOU KNOW, HELPS THEM
SIGNIFICANTLY, BUT I'D BE
WILLING TO CONSIDER IT. THANK
YOU. SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS TRY TO
BE BRIEF. THIS IS A TWO YEAR
BILL. THERE'S ARMS. OBVIOUSLY
LOTS OF CONVERSATION REGARDING
THIS BILL. LOTS OF CONCERNS. I
THINK, AS SENATORS, WE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT ANY BILL WE SEND
TO THE ASSEMBLY. THAT'S GOING TO
BE WORKED ON. UH AND THE
CONDITION IS GOING TO COME BACK
IN. I WOULD RECOMMEND TO THE
AUTHOR THAT HE JUST LET THIS
BILL UH, STAY HERE AND THEN RE
INTRODUCED A NEW BILL FOR THE
NEW LEGISLATIVE YEAR AND LET'S
GET IT TO THE PROPER COMMITTEES
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PASSING
A GOOD BILL OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY
GOING TO, YOU KNOW, VOTE ON
THIS, BILL. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
BEEN VERY ROBUST. SENATOR
BECKER, YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK
YOU, UM. DO YOU WANT TO SAY? I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES? UM. AND I THINK
THERE'S A BALANCE TO BE STRUCK
HERE. UM AND MANY MY CONGRESSMAN
DIEGO COLLEGE, MARK COUNTY JUST
MENTIONED IT. UM AND IT WAS
MENTIONED OVER HERE AS WELL. I
THINK THERE IS A BALANCE TO BE
STRUCK. AND UM AND I THINK THAT
WE CAN STRIKE IT. I THINK WE CAN
STRIKE THIS BALANCE. UM THIS
BILL HAS GONE THROUGH A LOT OF
VETTING. SOME OF THESE CONCERNS
ARE NEW. WE HAVEN'T REALLY HEARD
CONCERNS DIRECTLY. UM ABOUT YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE HECKLERS OR
SOME OF THOSE FOLKS, UH, THAT'S
REALLY HONESTLY A NEW CONCERN.
HAVING WORKED ON THIS FOR THREE
YEARS, BUT I'M WILLING TO
ADDRESS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
ADDRESS THAT COMMITTED TO
ADDRESS THAT. I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED THAT THE
DELAY THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
WILLING TO. UM LOOK AT AS WELL.
UM BUT I DON'T THINK THAT THE
PROBLEM WITH WAITING IN THIS
BILL IS EVERY YEAR THAT GOES BY
MORE FOLKS ENCRYPT. AND THEY'RE
GOING TO CITY COUNCILS. THOSE
CITY COUNCILS DON'T KNOW ALL THE
ISSUES THEY'RE SAYING, HEY, WE
NEED ALL THIS MONEY WE HAVE TO
ENCRYPT. AND THEN THAT PUTS MORE
ENTRENCHMENT FOR FOLKS WHO DON'T
WANT TO PROVIDE ACCESS, SO I DO
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE KEEP THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD
. I APPRECIATE THE CAUSE
DEPRESSANT COLLEAGUE FROM
BOREDOM PARK PRESSED ME VERY
SPECIFICALLY ON A LOT OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE COME UP TODAY,
A LOT OF CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED. UM SO I APPRECIATE THOSE
CONCERNS. I DO THINK, THOUGH,
THAT WE DO NOT WANT TO CONTINUE
TO DELAY THIS BECAUSE, UM, AS I
SAID, YOU KNOW, SINCE I STARTED
WORKING ON THIS A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO, A LOT MORE PEOPLE
HAVE ENCRYPTED A LOT MORE
ENTRENCHMENT. AND I THINK THE
SOONER WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
TO HAVE THIS BALANCE, AND I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE IT OVER IN THE
ASSEMBLY. THINK THE SOONER WE
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION, THE
BETTER AND WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETTA. ASHBY NÓ ATKINS
ALRIGHT BECKER. ALRIGHT
BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
AYE, CABALLERO. ALRIGHT,
CORTESI. ALRIGHT, DOLLY! NÓ
DODD. NÓ DURAZO. AYE, EGGMAN.
GLASER. GONZALES. GROVE. NO
SHADOW. JONES. NO LARD. ALRIGHT
LIMÓN. AYE, MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT,
MENJIVAR. MEN. NEWMAN. NO. WHEN
NÓ NILO. NO TRIAL. BORG NÓ
PORTANTINO ALRIGHT, ROTH. RUBIO.
SUHARTO. NÓ SKINNER. SMALLER
CUEVAS. AYE, STERN. ALRIGHT.
HAMBURG. HA! WIENER WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
AYE. I BROUGHT A GIRL. NO ARCHER
LETTER. EGGMAN. GLASER.
GONZALES. TODD Ó. MANY OF OUR
MEN. BY THE YEAR. ROTH. RUBIO.
NUMBER AHA! WILK NÓ. SENATOR
BECKER MOVES THE CALL. IF
EVERYBODY COULD PLEASE STAY ON
THE FLOOR, PLEASE. WE ARE ALMOST
DONE.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM NUMBER 12. ARE
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE
ALREADY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARCHULETTA. HAGMAN. GLASER.
GONZALES. SHADOW. BEN JABBAR.
MEN. BY THE RATH. RUBIO.
HAMBURG. AHA! ON CALL AGAIN.
MEMBERS. WE'RE BACK IN SESSION,
AND WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL. WE WILL BE GOING THROUGH
THE ROYAL CALLED TWICE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ARCHULETTA.
HAGMAN. GLASER. GONZALES. TODD
Ó. MENJIVAR. MEN. BY THE AH
ROTH. RUBIO. HAMBURG. AHA! WHAT
HAVE I. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN. ARCHULETTA. EGGMAN.
GLASER. GONZALES. DODD, Ó.
MENJIVAR. MEN. BY THE BROAD.
RUBIO. HAMBURG. I 17 NO 12. THE
BILL FAILS. IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS. WELL HE COULD DO
PROTEST MADKINS DESK IS CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. COLLEAGUES THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR THURSDAY. FEBRUARY 1ST 2024
AT 9 A.M. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL 330 AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED. WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT NINE AM THANK YOU
ALL.